ah
[Música]
a
desde el inicio de la pandemia en brasil
han muerto 451 indígenas según los datos
del ministerio de sanidad sin embargo
para la articulación de pueblos
indígenas de brasil serían 841 porque
también se incluyen a aquellos que viven
en las ciudades y no solo a los que
residen en las reservas entre los
fallecidos hay varios líderes
reconocidos internacionalmente los
indígenas piden más acción al gobierno
de bolsonaro que se escuda en una
operación llamada kobe 19 empezada en
marzo y que en siete meses ha llevado
más de 700.000 mascarillas y 25
mililitros de hidrogel a todos los
rincones del país movilizando a más de
30.000 militares sin embargo para los
indígenas se trata simplemente de una
operación de marketing y piden una
acción verdadera contra los verdaderos
responsables de propagar el virus que
son los invasores ilegales de sus
reservas
eso es madereros y buscadores de oro
[Música]
en perú el coi 19 se propagó en las
ciudades y luego se expandió por los
territorios de los pueblos indígenas
diversos colectivos denuncian que el
sistema de salud del país no los
consideren sus reportes pero la
asociación interétnica de desarrollo de
la selva peruana aidesep registra el
contagio por coronavirus de más de
21.000 indígenas y estima que el número
de muertes en las comunidades puede
llegar a 3000 a lo largo de 11 regiones
del perú se señala que el 61 por ciento
de estas comunidades carecen de un
establecimiento de salud en sus
territorios los indígenas con mejor
suerte se sanaron con remedios
ancestrales el resto murió al interior
de sus casas las organizaciones
indígenas alertan que el mortal patógeno
les está quitando la vida a decenas de
líderes de los pueblos originarios con
ellos muere la cosmovisión nativa las
tradiciones de sus antepasados y también
las lenguas originarias ante esta
emergencia el gobierno peruano anunció
que atenderá a más de 400 mil indígenas
en situación de vulnerabilidad a quienes
se les brindará abastecimiento de
alimentos de primera necesidad y
atención sanitaria
[Música]
la organización nacional indígena de
colombia informó que hasta octubre se
habían contagiado más de 27.000
indígenas y más de 1.000 habían muerto
por el quabit 19 un virus que en
septiembre había llegado a más de 70
comunidades indígenas de colombia
algunas de las cuales están en peligro
de desaparición una de las primeras
zonas afectadas fue la amazonía el temor
de la llegada de un nuevo virus ponía en
peligro a los pueblos originarios de la
zona quienes en muchos casos no estaban
preparados para enfrentar una pandemia
entre los motivos de su vulnerabilidad
la dificultad para mantener medidas de
bioseguridad organismos más vulnerables
desprotección y en algunas comunidades
carencia de agua y desnutrición sin
embargo el kobe 19 es sólo uno de los
factores que amenazan a las comunidades
indígenas la violencia del país y el
activismo social y medioambiental de los
pueblos originarios colombianos les ha
llevado a pedir la intervención de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos por la persecución
criminalización amenazas de asesinatos
que viven a pesar de la pandemia
[Música]